how's it going red my name is pewdiepie
and welcome to journey i've been looking
forward to play this game
for almost a year now this game was
announced
game of the year by a lot of a lot of
it's won a lot of awards
similar to that a lot of nominations a
lot of people are saying it's the game
of the year
it's very innovative in the sense that
well you'll see it eventually there's no
point in me just keep talking about it
the point is let's start a new journey
hell yeah it already reminds me so much
with this song music
of shadow of the classes it feels like
i'm playing it
[Music]
it's sand i think yes i remember i
played it with a friend
like six months ago for like a couple
minutes so i know the basics
it's not gonna be a surprise or anything
there's gonna be sand
spoilers [ __ ] i spoil it to you
honey i don't mean to it's also a very
short game
i think it's like three hours or
something like that maybe even two
so um let's go on a journey bus
are you ready i'm sorry i understand
that every morning
is that us
i think that's us
we are freaking fast too holy [ __ ]
what oh we saw that
and we're gonna follow it is that it am
i getting this right
we are a cat cat uh
okay whoa
cool cool and we're
i got it
love the controls in this game it's
awesome all right online
uh no connect
okay i gotta fix that all right i don't
want to spoil it to anyone
uh who doesn't know what's gonna happen
so let's just keep going
it's really gorgeous this game like
really you'd think a desert would be
boring but nope
come on girl what are we gonna call him
by the way we need a name for him or her
i think it's her
what should we call him her ah
[ __ ] all right it's gonna climb the sand
dune and we'll see if we get a better
view up from this
hill whoa
look at that gorgeous
so i guess that's where the star fell or
whatever it is i don't know
all right well are these what are these
like grave tombs
no why would they bury someone in the
desert that'll make no sense
jumping sliding
all right what's up
nothing i'm fine what's up sam
let's go inside i don't know why i'm
wearing this awesome red cape
i feel like i'm little red riding hood
or something like that
kind of makes me feel like it but desert
edition or something
all right we got something over here
let's check it out bras
i wish i could sprint or something i
know you can kind of
what what the hell am i singing
go okay it jumps automatically
[ __ ] you what is that
uh we got something here bryce
i collected something
i don't know what but i did it
paper sheets i got a little tail now
hold x
awesome oh and i collect them is that it
do i lose them if i jump how does it
work yeah okay
cool i'll save this for later
you never know when you can knead them
all right let's follow the grape oh
there's more of them here might as well
fly under wings of literary riding hood
slide baby slide
jumping like a bu i feel like i'm one of
those squirrels holy [ __ ] i can do
barrel roll
i mean front flips could be i don't know
what it's called in english
when you do a front flip it's just
called a front flip
oh okay i think it sounds better in
swedish
like the ugliest word ever all right we
got some sort of temple here
that's pretty cool it's [ __ ] gorgeous
it's not i don't know very atmospheric
game let's slide down here
slide to the left slide to the right
jumping up here
collect them no fine see if i care
[Music]
still don't have a name for it though
have you commented the name i'll check
it i promise
that's a really ugly name you try harder
all right oh okay that's a good one
i'll stop i'm sorry okay let's go out
there
see what we can find well
i got a new ability what is that
i can sing and singing
unlocks more carpets
i [ __ ] love carpets i don't know if i
ever told you that
i like them on facebook it's a great
great fan booth
about carpets i can show
you the world
oh i collect them by whoa whoa
i'm fly on the wings of pills
this game is exceeding my expectations
so far i love it
what is he looking at what's she looking
at the eagle what if we sing at it
hello eagle
eagle why don't you do anything i need
to activate it somehow
oh okay there we go
eagle heard me sing now i just sit down
and this game's beautiful
what's going on now i like the unibrow
by the way
gorgeous unibrow
what's happening
all right they're not being too
straightforward with the
story at least which i like i like it
better told in a theme
sort of sense so that's the sky
i don't know are those birds
pla okay cool
[Music]
what do we got here so there's
five of us and some of us look like
camels
[Music]
what what is this
do you get this maybe it'll be obvious
in the end or something like that
all i know for now is that the eagle is
a bro
because he opened this door aloha she's
sitting down in the meanwhile
very nice legs by the way she must do
really good
exercises i want to know her diet
now that i need it i mean i'm going i'm
fabulous
we are entering the other side look
at this love with epic architecture
[Music]
for sure all right so it's saving we
made it to the first
place let's play a little more shall we
all right i think now is where the
interesting part
is uh coming along i would assume don't
worry
i don't know this game more than you do
probably
don't don't look at me like he knows
everything already he's just pretending
that
i get that a lot i always i always play
without knowing what's going on because
you bros
keep saying that you don't you don't
want me to know what's going on but then
in the end you're like pierce you don't
know what's going on so it's like
it's an unlimited i'm just gonna fly on
the wings
here are some carpets so i'm gonna get
these
look at that cooler
all right uh
all right we gotta go look around here
and see what we're doing i guess we
gotta go update
and build the bridge or some [ __ ] like
that
fly that did not work
i think i need more of them
oh yeah i do this to collect them i
forgot
there we go that'd not work
fly fly my friend fly
no what about whoa whoa whoa whoa what
okay i did something
who's over there hello fran hello i'm
not alone what's your name
big magnusson my god thank magnus on
you'll look a lot thinner hello friend
let's go i will sing to you
let it be let it be
singing words of wisdom
[Music]
oh [ __ ] he's good at flying big man why
i'm impressed he missed this one though
looks like i'll be the one doing all the
hard work so in case you haven't figured
out yet
i'm i'm playing randomly with another
what's
we're building the bridge yet
all right cool i didn't see the first
one
probably just didn't pay attention to it
there where's my friend where did he go
oh there he is
don't lay me like that friend oh he's
good at surfing
i love you bank magnusson
it's so cute in a sense it's probably
like a
50 year old
never mind let's just pretend it's like
something cute going on here
with me and bank management all right
let me let me dream my god damn it
fly underway all right here's another
carpet
so what i'm saying it's a random guy or
girl on the other side that we're
playing with
oh what is he saying oh he's collecting
those i want those they're mine
all right he's clearly a lot better at
this than me ah
caught up with him where is he going
is there another one up here yeah
there's two of them all right
can't get up here yep can't can
and will i need these carpets to get up
i think
i don't even know i think i need these
don't really understand what's so
magical about carpets but hey i'm
rolling with it i'll let him take that
one
penguin is on you do that one and i'll
i'll do the hard work all right
doesn't work i wasted mine didn't i
there we go fly on the wings of piers
[Music]
yeah baby
all right there's another one over here
big money son i don't know if you can
hear me bank manga son but
oh [ __ ] i should have taken those damn
it
he's gonna fly so awesome nearly now
i'm sliding in the meanwhile because we
have this one left
what's going on did we finish it oh we
finished it
oh cool
such a beautiful game man don't you love
it i love it so far i think it's really
cool
all right let's keep going
where's bengt oh there he is bang don't
run away okay
i'm scared being alone now no i stole
your carpets didn't i
it's okay you can have them
[Music]
fly with banked magnusson
fly banksy fly i'm going to sing this
song at least
five or six other times so get used to
it
my carpets
[Music]
whew look at that look
and match here all right
let's wait for bangs there he is
gonna cross this epic bridge i want to
hold his hand
there we go it's you and me banksy boo
that's a new name
always with ew
digging the music you can see my panties
[ __ ] bank isn't supposed to see it look
at them
that a good old pervert
[Music]
all right so i really don't know about
the story so far i
i'm told that it's supposed to have like
an epic thing in the end
so i'm looking forward to see what it's
gonna be like i'll take the one on the
left banked
we have to talk to the eagle you know
you take bank doesn't know what he's
doing
come on bang you're better than that
all right the eagle has been sunk to
let's sit down
paint
uh what is this
who is that person is that my mama
[Music]
i'm black and she's white it's the ying
and the yang
i don't know she seems much more
beautiful too
all right the story continues i don't
understand the story
so okay it's what we've done so far
isn't it yeah we went up there
hmm
that looks kind of like a train but i
don't think it is
all right so this is what's coming next
i would assume
the two of us will unlock the temple
somehow i don't even know
let me check
all right sorry about that
all right the eagle has landed i repeat
the eagle hat whoa awesome
look at that gorgeous bang
wait for me man oh crazy [ __ ]
bang bang fine
see if i care and we got another save
all right bros
i think i will end this episode here
[ __ ] gorgeous game man
uh like compared if you enjoyed and want
to see more i'll be happy to play more
this is awesome i'm actually going to
keep playing more
you don't get to see it say other
[ __ ] it feels like this random [ __ ]
just happens every day
what see what i'm talking about